election night is a is about the
presidential race first and foremost um
but now that i have been endorsing
all of these down ballot candidates uh
some of whom are hardcore yang gang
some of whom are for cash relief um
there's virtually no one on the list
that's not one of those two things
[Laughter]
like if you're uh really i mean if we
endorsed you
for cash relief yeah uh
so i'm gonna be very very intent on
seeing what happens to a lot of these
candidates particularly a lot of the um
challengers to incumbents being an
incumbent member of congress
is so hard under ordinary circumstances
it's one reason why you notice any time
it does happen because it just never
happens
um but i think if there's going to be a
time for it to happen it's going to be
this time
so for context the historical reelection
rate for an incumbent member of congress
is 94
that's sky high that's better than the
golden state warriors in their record
year kind of high
uh good analogy but so it is so if
uh this time it's going to be lower
though because you have a lot of
um a lot of incumbents who are
vulnerable or in a contested race
and you're seeing record levels of
turnout
the real challenge if andrew gang is
correct uh
and also our processes hold up not a
given um
and that votes are counted and there's
an orderly transfer of power
uh and joe gets sworn in january 2 first
really to me that then the work begins
uh you know you need to work work work
to win this election
i'm working very hard to uh try and grow
the number of members of congress that
are for cash relief and so you know like
where we're working
uh but then the real work begins
after you're in power whether you
actually
make enough big changes so that the
problems that got trump elected
don't just fester and grow and there's
been a consistent narrative
from a number of people that i find very
very interesting and we're going to find
out one way or another
and here's a narrative you all heard it
i think
that trump for all of his problems
uh is not as
competent or fascist as you can imagine
arising from a truly disintegrating
civilization where if we don't solve the
problems that got trump elected
something else comes out of the same
set of ideas and impulses and people uh
and that person could be worse than
trump that person could be
uh competent and malignant as well as
narcissistic
you know that that person could um
really
put much more
design into some of the
darker tendencies that trump represented
whereas trump was kind of
uh bowling china shop like that that was
his vibe and approach
um and i think that's
one concern that i find by the way
totally legitimate
nature reports a vacuum and the rest of
it uh you know like
does the post-presidency trump remain
trump are there like other versions that
kind of spin out
in various ways you know there's this
massive level of energy
around uh some of these ideas and
conspiracy theories and impulses from
the fact that q anon has become an
actual
political movement despite just starting
out as
um internet conspiracy theories you know
i mean that
that's pretty wild so uh
so the challenges are going to begin
almost after election day and
you're sworn in uh the the thing that
philip howard said really stuck with me
he said the parties have been playing
you lose i lose you lose i lose all the
time
while we have been losing ourselves or
like the people have been losing
and the temptation for
joe and the dems is going to be we won
we beat trump
everything's back to normal we can just
do our thing
and because we're sane and rational and
well-intended
um uh all should be well and uh you
should
believe in us uh and a lot of americans
don't believe
because uh they just don't think that
our government is working for them
uh and actually solving the problems
they see around them uh
the fact that we don't have a stimulus
relief bill by the way is
exhibit uh 378 and their list of like
why i don't believe in government
it's an awfully big exhibit it's like a
bigger exhibit than some of the others
so the challenge
uh is going to be manifold but it's
strengthening the connection between
government and
the reality on the ground for many
americans if we don't build up
that connection we don't build up the
trust the mistrust is just going to grow
the institutional deterioration is just
going to grow
and the danger is that we become
increasingly ungovernable and unable to
solve meaningful problems over time
i think this is the real danger i think
we're going to win this election
and then the question is whether we go
big enough and whether we rebuild in a
way that's
robust enough and i know this
if and let's say when we win um there
are people like you
people like aoc people like a lot of the
candidates we've endorsed that will not
let this administration and we'll be
allies to them as much as we can but
we'll not let them be complacent as if
things are normal like you are step one
on a long road to recovery i want to go
through all the humanity forward
candidates
and what happened with their races i now
am so passionate about so many of these
candidates i'm going to be
pumped when they win and very sad if
they don't win because i feel like they
all deserve to win
some of them have very tough races but
if you're listening to this and you can
help in any of the humanity forward
races
please check it out go to
movehumanityforward.com
who knows it could be the person running
in your district uh and then you can go
vote for them
but let's help them win that's going to
be to me
uh a massive uh like emotional
high or low what happens with those
candidates um because having been a
candidate myself
i see what they put on the line and if
they win some of them they win
that it's going to be historic because
some of them are awesome
candidates and human beings but running
in districts where
no one gave them a shot in the beginning
but now some of them do have a shot
yeah the best thing we can do to broaden
what you stand for andrew is actually
empowering the people we've
we've tasked with carrying the torch you
know we've given our glasses who are
carrying the torch
so that's movement forward you can
actually donate to all of them like if
you only have five bucks to donate you
can give
a little fraction to all of them which
is you know pennies i guess so please
give more than that if you're doing that
but uh
like you can give you can see them all
um and they need like joe biden like
um they're good on money i think down
the stretch here
they're good like you know um but some
of these smaller candidates really could
like you know
100 bucks or whatever you can give
actually would go a decent way because
they're doing a lot of facebook ads or
flyer printing and get out the vote
efforts
day of and that's that actually carries
some weight in some of these small
accounts too so
i've donated to our candidates uh it
it's just so
fun you can't resist um and then after
you donate there's a magical connection
that is forged
some of you have that connection with me
so if you want to root even harder
for candidate election night just make a
donation
10 20 bucks to them and then all of a
sudden you'll be like that's my guy or
that's my gal or that's my candidate
um so i'd encourage you to do so it
really is magical
that connection it's one reason why i
think those organic campaigns
like ours end up being so much stronger
uh because you feel like you own it uh
you
be through your support and like it or
not
uh that that includes financial support
there's something very direct and
powerful about it you know what's cool
andrew that we actually don't talk about
enough is that
you interview every candidate
we endorse or about to endorse um
and no offense to barack obama he makes
a lot of endorsements i highly doubt
he's doing that
um like you get to know them personally
and there have been times
um where you're like you know i don't
know if this is you know like you'll
you want to get to know that on a
personal level to make sure they um that
frankly the yang gang or anyone's
donating to them
um yeah i personally interview them and
i personally donate to them
uh if if we decide to go forward and
i've definitely talked to someone i've
been like i don't know if this is the
the way or this is the fit um because i
feel terrible endorsing someone if i
didn't have that direct
experience with them even if it is a
half an hour zoom or phone call
and you can go a long way with a half an
hour zoomer phone call and getting
into someone's head and seeing what
makes them tick and now i love those
candidates
i'll tell you like if i'd endorsed them
and i hadn't had that conversation with
them would i feel as strongly as i do
heck no
you'd be a phony yeah but now i'm so
into it i'm so into each and every one
of them
they're awesome i don't want to name
names it's like having some you know but
like
donna david kim kara eastman in nebraska
in that district you're talking about
the folks who are on yank speaks last
week
uh pam keith allen cohn
uh you know though this just goes on and
on i love them all should you call
carney
like lulacycly anyway
uh they're all so pretty dude do check
them out
at movehumanityforward.com let's help
them win that's
going to be a roller coaster for me on
election night because i can already see
some of them are going to win i'm sure
some of them are not going to win
because many of them have very
challenging races
but i'm going to be like yes yes oh no
yes oh no and then i'll be you know and
some of you won't know
i'll be texting them too i'll be all
like yeah
so excited or like you did great anyway
um yeah anyway so election night it's
gonna be a huge night let's make it even
better
make sure and vote you can still make a
difference you can still donate you can
still volunteer you can still do all
sorts of things
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to
yangspeaks and click on notifications so
we can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you